it's challenging to go to the UN and
participate in the system where the UN
says you know we have this formula and
every country gets to have a certain
amount of people get jobs at the UN so
they look at the formula and they say oh
well how many people do we have from
Nigeria oh we need more go hire people
into the system from Nigeria it tends to
not be whether or not someone is
qualified more has the skill set it is
are we being fair and equal on the
disbursement of jobs out of this idea
lately right and that's where it breaks
down because you're hiring people that
really don't know what they're doing and
they waste money and the UN becomes a
jobs program hey I'm Dave Rubin and this
is the Rubin report as always guys make
sure you subscribe to our YouTube
channel and click that notification bell
so that you have a small chance of
actually seeing our videos in your feed
and more importantly joining me today is
the former US spokesman at the UN and
currently the American ambassador to
Germany
Rick Grinnell welcome to the Rubin
report pretty amazing this is really
cool pretty amazing this is really cool
I gotta tell you I thought and my team
thought we're bringing in our first
ambassador the Ambassador from Germany
the country important powerful guy we
thought you were gonna be in a sharp
suit you'd bring us German chocolates
and treats things like that I have never
had a more casual guest in this studio
mr. ambassador I would say that this is
because of you right yeah because I
figured I'm in a suit all the time but
if Dave is gonna interview me I better
be pretty casual I know your crowd is
pretty casual my crowd is casual I feel
like I should be wearing I have that
same hoodie I could be should we stop
right now but do you have the same I
don't have the gay mustache t-shirt
available at Target is that a target
that's target you truly are a banner
people yeah all right we got a lot to
talk about so I realized yesterday when
I was doing a little research on you
because that's what I do that that you
know even even write everything they say
about you must be true right I'm pretty
sure that's how it works online and
Wikipedia they're not
they're anything but even though we've
been friends for a couple years now and
I know you pretty well I realized that I
actually don't know anything about your
life like childhood or anything I don't
even know where you're from and I
started doing some reading and I was
like that I'm just gonna blitz pick it
up here cuz you're the ambassador
Germany the hell are you from how did
this whole thing happen it was born in
Muskegon Michigan my parents mu I'm the
youngest of four kids and so my parents
moved to California in Redwood City
actually and so I went to elementary
school in Redwood City moved back to
Michigan in seventh grade so I went to
junior high in high school all in in
Jennison Michigan and then I went my
parents are evangelical which I know you
know I grew up evangelical I went to
Evangel College which is the national
liberal arts school for the Assemblies
of God evangelical movement great school
had an amazing experience small it's in
Springfield Missouri and then worked on
Capitol Hill for a little while worked
for a presidential campaign of 92 and
then went to the Kennedy School and got
a master's at the Kennedy School and
then kind of kept doing political stuff
were you always into politics as a kid
yes which is crazy I love the media I
loved watching the news with my dad
and we'd sit down together and watch the
news and talk about these issues my dad
was pretty political in the sense that
he he liked to talk about politics and
would always be involved in in the local
you know congressional race of
supporting somebody basically and
stuffing envelopes and so he gave me
that kind of excitement
I like the pure competition of it in
many ways I'm a very competitive person
there's nothing like having two
campaigns that are jostling and then
there's an election day right there's
like a finish line there's a day that
everybody votes who did it better and
who do I like and and that pure Gladish
all depends on what the Russians decide
that's true that's true but I like that
that whole competition thing about
politics and I think a lot of people go
into it because of the pure fun and
political competition of it I also am
geeky and care about policy and I and I
love to
dig deep on policy and make change make
the world a better place does it shock
you the amount of people that are in
politics that are endlessly miserable
related to politics like I see so much
of that now or it's like these people
who think that all of their life and
their whole salvation yeah
politics it's like it only can lead you
to disaster or depression somehow where
if you have a certain different look
where it's not everything yeah
it's not everything then you can kind of
have a smile on your face when you talk
about it you know I think that it's
largely if you live in Washington DC I
mean that's a it's a set incestuous town
of people who you know on both sides the
aisle they their kids go to the same
school and they go to the same church
and so they protect each other and and
they live in Washington and they just
kind of flip when it's the Obama
administration all my Democrat friends
isn't are connected and they include me
in the in the local you know dining
experience in social circles and then
when my guy is in and they're out I'll
take care of them and and lobbyists are
all there and the whole city is growing
it's such a terrible place the real
world outside of Washington DC I think
gives you perspective and so I have
worked in the political realm for like
more than 25 years I've only lived in
Washington from 1993 to 1995 I got out I
can't stand going back and and I think
that gives you perspective it's not
unlike here in LA where we both live
it's you know if if you're a part of
Hollywood and you're you're working at a
studio and all you live and breathe is
the blogs and the TV media you know
Hollywood stuff you you don't get a very
good perspective it's the actors who
moved to Atlanta mm-hmm or who moved
their production companies to you know
Chicago or Montana who I think have
better perspective and they do better
work because they have just a different
view how has then being in Germany
living in Germany as our ambassador and
Germany change your perspective on
American politics when you see it from
not just not living in DC but actually
living abroad yeah
so I actually asked for the job to be
ambassador to Germany and one of
reasons why is my eight years at the UN
taught me this kind of lesson if you've
ever been to the UN and you walk into
that huge General Assembly Hall 193
placards looking at you it feels like
the superfriends the Hall of
Superfriends I took the tour when I was
in like ninth grade yeah that's the only
time it does feel like the Hall of Super
Friends but as an American or like the
Legion of Doom though yeah for sure when
you walk in that Hall and you see 193
countries as an American you quickly say
where are my European friends because we
view the world the same way when it
comes to democracy rule of law human
rights you know you're not trying to
convince European countries too that
they shouldn't shove a gay person off a
building we have the relatively the same
perspective and so I found that in my
eight years at the UN in dealing with
the Europeans we we tend to as Americans
negotiate with what we call the III the
British the French and the Germans our
experience with the III became that the
Germans were the weakest of the ìiî they
were dragging down our negotiations with
with the Europeans can you give me an
example of how they would do that sort
of thing so I'll give you a recent
example I would say when the UN finally
came around and gave a second report
that Bashar al-assad had gassed children
and gassed people and we the West the
Western alliance wanted to respond to
that the Americans approached the
British and they said we're in we
approached the French and they said what
do you need we approached the Germans
and they said we don't like war we're
against war you know we've had this
special history and so we really don't
want to to participate in war anymore
and so I've actually said to Chancellor
Merkel and to the Foreign Minister and
lots of people in Germany that's the
wrong lesson of World War two the lesson
of World War two for the Germans is that
they should be the first ones to
recognize a madman who's gassing
children and that they should be in the
front of the bus and they should say
let's form a call it now I get that
because of their special
history they don't want to do it alone
anymore mm-hmm
and so they they literally want to be
surrounded by multilateralism great but
you had that with the French the British
and the Americans and they still
couldn't participate so I think we're in
a slide over the last year's and one of
the things I wanted to solve was this
Germany first economic model but Germany
wanting to have a Switzerland foreign
policy where they're gonna be friends
with everybody and just cash in I mean
Germany is really the first country in
terms of the economics to be a Germany
first policy mm-hmm and America first is
only coming along a little while later
but the Germans have been doing it for a
while so that's a pretty big split sort
of if Germany's going Germany first
economically but then on the world stage
we kind of got a dip out because of our
history did Merkel respond to you in a
positive way when he said you know we
should be more or you when you should be
more involved look I think the
Chancellor does have an innate good
reaction to say we should do more and we
should participate and we should pay our
NATO bills even though they're not and
try to get I want to talk about I do
think that she she thinks that that's
important but that it's a lofty goal
because they really want to bring the
public along first and no politician in
Germany wants to step out and be a
leader now remember the German word for
leader is Fuehrer which is too close to
to the word that that they used for
Hitler and so many times talking about
being a leader conjures up really
negative stereotypes and so try being
the US ambassador to Germany asking the
Germans to do more without using the
word leader yeah how do you say be you
can't say be a leader you have to say
step out and and you know what do you
say you can't even say lead by example
do you think there is like an actual
sort of psychological condition then
that they will ever be able to get out
of do you think it's just like so
embedded in the
eat those of what it means to be German
now because of the history I mean first
of all let's let's just say what it's
pretty serious
no it's a it's an incredible monumental
stain that lasts through generations and
I'll tell you one of the things the
dynamics that we've experienced in
Germany is that there are now young
people who are trying to be tech
entrepreneurs or run businesses and you
hear will little whisper campaigns up to
say oh you know they have their money or
their house because they were
sympathizers with the Nazis or they
didn't stand up against the Nazis so
there is still this very societal
competition of finger-pointing who was
good and who was bad and imagine if we
had to talk about our grandparents as
whether or not they stood up or whether
or not they took cover and they tried to
you know do what they had to do pretty
incredible kind of monumental things to
think about and so I would say one of
the things that I see is as we as the
Westerners when we hear never again we
all think never again means never again
will you slaughter people and and get to
the point where you your hatred becomes
the systematic killing right never again
for many Germans means never again are
we gonna have any military role mm-hmm
they don't necessarily believe that
never again means you can have a working
military that defends your country and
participates in good around the world
and and never again just means don't
don't let it get out of hand but for
them in many ways never again just means
no military operations whatsoever god we
I mean we could do show up on show on
that yeah sure I'm sure in Germany
they're doing that all the time and
trying to work through that you'd be
surprised the German media is pretty
groupthink not many step out well I told
you last night about my experience with
the German media yeah they called I
could resolve that for you so easy if
you would have just said to me I got a
call from a Spiegel reporter
would have said Dave hang up now I mean
come on they've made up stories about
Americans constantly they got caught
making they got cars yeah and then they
took them a year to kind of admit it and
the whole time they're saying oh we have
the best fact-checking system in the
world think they couldn't in fact check
to save their life just was like for the
people that don't remember they put a
picture of me on the cover of the
magazine saying I'm the grand
illusionist of the all right and you can
see my big American flag over there yes
and I was sitting in front of the
American flag like this and it looks
like I'm some like all right leader and
they're talking about my Scandinavian
furniture which is IKEA and my fancy
Italian coffee maker which is Nespresso
I mean the whole thing very anyways
sidebar all right let's go back to the
safety that I know yeah how did I not
call you idiot all right well let's back
up for a second because you mentioned
your evangelical upbringing and then you
showed me your gay mustache shirt Rick I
thought this is not possible I thought
evangelicals can't be gay or Christian
theology and and homosexuality are at
odds or all of these things you strike
me as a decent functioning person and
we've had dinner with you and Matt and
all that good stuff so make some sense
out of this you know I think being gay
makes me a better Christian to be honest
it I'll tell you this I I have felt
guilty this is an admission that when I
had cancer and I was really kind of down
in terms of my physical outlook I felt
like I prayed more and I was closer to
God because I was in need right I feel
guilty about that as I go through life
and and of course the the ups and downs
of life when when things are going well
you don't pray as much you don't really
think about God or the the existence of
the creator and I started to feel really
guilty about that and so I just think
that that every person needs to have you
know whether it's a group of people or a
philosophy of some sort that keeps them
in check then the kind of questions what
life's ups are
about and and so for me being gay I
think I get so much challenge that you
can't be gay and be a Christian that it
makes me a better Christian it makes I
mean I'm an imperfect follower of Christ
I'm I fail every single day but you know
for me what's the beauty of this is that
you know the Bible talks about having
new mercies every morning and grace
every morning I get up every morning and
I just think thank God that I believe in
the Creator and that every morning I
have a new beginning and a new chance to
to prove myself in this totally human
state that fails every day and so I was
made this way right and the Bible says
everyone is fearfully and wonderfully
made I was made this way I was born gay
so the fact of the matter is is that I
fully embrace the fact that I was made
this way in the image of God and you can
be gay and be a Christian and there's no
problem with it
I think the world is also changing
within the church that the church really
believes that and when you look at the
biblical kind of mantra about this you
really have to go back to the original
language the original Greek and and and
really understand what the words were
when it when the translation in the
1950s somehow takes the word
homosexuality and puts it into a
different context I don't know if you
know Peter Gomes he passed away but
Peter was my was the minister at Harvard
Memorial Church and he was conservative
and black and gay and a minister and he
was an incredible and just a little
literally an incredible mentor to me to
think about how God made me and what the
Bible says about really a whole bunch of
these kind of 20th century issues the
subjugation of women immigration all
these he wrote this book called the good
book and he takes all these issues and
goes back to show how both sides of the
argument over the years have used the
Bible in their favor they've said things
like you know God has told me to to
you know have this position and you
manipulated on both sides and he kind of
showed look stop with the minute
manipulators and look at what the
original language says I love things
like that it's like an exit genesis of
the words and the time yeah do you think
that something particularly good or
interesting is happening with the
evangelical community generally i was
telling you last night I mean I spoke at
Liberty University in front of 14,000
people they know that I'm gay not only
could I I didn't sense that one person
cared in some sort of negative sense you
know yeah people I walk around campus
everybody was incredibly nice the amount
of emails that I get from evangelicals
in the middle of the country who
actually most of them say they usually
say they don't care that I'm gay or they
don't even know often and that yeah
they'll say I was watching you for two
years until I even found out they'll say
I don't even care which is which is sort
of how you want an I also do this right
now you now just really blown my cover
here with your with your gay mustache
shirt but do you sense that something
has shifted with the evangelicals where
maybe you know during the George W Bush
re-election year where they made gay
marriage such a wedge issue and totally
evangelicals were not behaving maybe
christ-like or however you want to put
it so I think there's two of two issues
in there that I would confront one on
the political side yes that it's
completely changing I have you know I
went to the 1992 convention in Houston
and I've been to every convention since
then let me tell you the 1992 convention
when speeches got up there and we're
very anti-gay yeah it's much too for
this is that was Bob Dole no that was
bush-quayle reelection
okay okay and so the we've made dramatic
changes every four years I could see the
convention and the political process
completely changing but let's let's also
talk about the fact you know my brother
is a very well-known evangelical
minister I've got nephews who are
evangelical pastors and so I know this
crowd really well and I think there's a
difference between the political nature
of the issues by them embracing things
like the decriminalization of
homosexuality around the world they
don't think countries should arrest
someone for being gay or
kill someone for being gay evangelicals
believe that they say no no you
shouldn't do that it's quite different
though to say are you gonna jump up and
down and and and be happy that two men
are getting married and do you approve
that I don't necessarily need the answer
to the second question yeah I don't
either I don't go around and approve the
marriages of people in my own family or
or people that come into my life I don't
sit there and say you know I don't know
if this should work we won't know plenty
of straight couples like that but I
don't wander around all day worrying
about it or if you really bring it up
every single time you around them you
probably wouldn't have a very good
friendship yeah when you were at dinner
with them to say like I don't get how
this works like you're a accomplished
person and you're a slouch you know you
just don't say things like that and we
don't judge other people's marriages so
to speak and so I that's worked with me
I just say to people I don't need
applause I don't need you to jump up and
down and scream happiness that you know
I am gay I just wanted to be equal yeah
and so I think there is an element I
hate to say it like this because because
this is way too simple but it is an
agree to disagree well as long as the
rights are equal I'm correct you you can
think whatever you want mean this is you
know people get pissed because I'm
friends with Ben Shapiro
and it's like he has his Orthodox Jewish
perspective on gay marriage yeah it's
not trying to stop me from being married
he may not build personally that I'm
married or have his own religious belief
and I knew you're right yeah
so what do I expect in this world you
know what I mean or what do I expect in
this country in a free country you know
I went to the 1993 march on Washington
for when when Bill Clinton and Al Gore
had taken over and that March was
incredible because there I'm gonna get
the number wrong and somebody's gonna
come out Oh God come at you yeah I think
it was like a million people right gays
and lesbians and and straight supporters
all came out to Washington and marched
and it was dramatic in that I think it
was at that point that that things
became political I'm gays and lesbians
and and the LGBT movement before the
and we've kind of all were on the outs
and so we were together we in Washington
you know people Republicans and
Democrats were not making this the wedge
issue but I will say that that the march
on Washington left our community with a
sense of we just want equality and if
you go back to that March Dave the
mantra was tolerance and diversity we
recognized that other people were not
going to agree with us and our whole
request our ask was just embrace
diversity we know you don't you don't
agree with everything that that you know
we stand for but let's just be tolerant
of each other
so remember hate is not a family value
was this whole thing yeah now the entire
leadership of the LGBT movement in
Washington DC is all about cancel
culture and absolutely pushing people
out of the argument to say I'm I don't
even want to be friends with you if you
voted for Trump or you're gay
conservative I can't even fathom being
friends with you well now they also want
to take your gayness away right so
they'll write articles that famous
article in out magazine about how Peter
teal is not gay enough because it's
because it's not who you have sex with
or who you love that makes you gay it's
actually a political yeah way of
thinking that makes you gay which is
which is why dad has this whole like
immigration and and it's a movement
beyond anything that has to do with gays
and lesbians and I think it's an exhibit
if they're trying to survive right well
is that just the cops need a certain
amount of crime type of thing it's like
we got equal rights and I say everything
is perfect and right but I work I work
around the world let me tell you it's
pretty people around the world who are
fighting for equality and and and I
really mean this they are totally
annoyed at the New York hollywood west
hollywood gays who raise a lot of money
for black-tie events and aren't doing a
thing to help our brothers and sisters
in lebanon who are getting arrested
or look what happened in Zambia they
literally prosecuted to two guys for
being gay and and the court said oh no
we're doing this because they're gay
they didn't make up some pedophilia say
I don't know but if you say something
about that you're somehow racist right
or you're as I opposed or something like
that because you're pushing your values
but some values are better than others
that must be the number one thing you
have to fight all the time right at the
UN over the years at the UN that you had
to fight that yeah as an ambassador well
I'm now fighting this thing at the State
Department where when it comes to the
decriminalization campaign so you're
you're spearheading this thing right I'm
spearheading this thing there's sixty
nine countries that criminalize
homosexuality ten will kill you for
being gay and we've launched a process
we've done a whole bunch we're trying to
stay out of the media in terms of
telling them every little thing because
the media is pretty hostile to something
like this we've we've we're making great
the wrong game is pretty hostile to
something like decriminalizing from the
Trump administration oh yeah I know well
we're get to that I was about to tell
you a second ago that we've talked for
about a half hour so and until about a
minute ago the T word had not come up
yet which i think is a record yeah but
what so we'll get to that in a second
that's very good but but the
decriminalization campaign it we're
making so much progress granted this is
gonna be a long fight trying to convince
69 countries to do a change in domestic
laws to to not criminalize homosexuality
and that's all this is a step one is
just to work on criminalization others
are working on step two through 20
mm-hmm I I felt the need to do step one
because when I look around the world
step one wasn't really being pushed I've
been working with no this is gonna be
bad because they're probably gonna go
after them but I've been working with
Stuart milk of the Harvey Milk
Foundation whose fantastic who's totally
focused on this problem and so what
we're trying to do is to have 69
different campaigns basically because
you've got to work with the local
community remarkable stories that I
could just go in over and over that I
don't because I don't want to highlight
it and scare people away that are
working in these country
but suffice to say this was a fight that
needed to happen that was not happening
and right now I have to face at the
State Department resistance from people
who don't want Americans or Westerners
to go into other countries and take a
stand for the decriminalization campaign
because literally there are countries
that believe that the West and
specifically America have imported into
their country being gay
mm-hmm and so they're like oh no no
American should talk about this because
you're gonna emphasize my position back
is that's the stupidest idea that
Americans brought in the gay right there
are many people before America it's only
about 200 year things right so I'm not
gonna actually be silent on that and
participate in letting them silence me
because they've got some crazy
conspiracy theory I'm gonna bust the
conspiracy theory wide open and say
you're wrong how do you decide though
when to use extra pressure to get a
country to do something because I know
as generally as a conservative and from
what I know about you you don't love the
idea of go of telling countries what to
do like yeah not really like in the
conservative ethos right and yet I
understand you want people to be free so
how do you decide when we can apply more
pressure question yeah I know when I get
one every interview that's the one I
would say that I have this philosophy
that that as a diplomat I am working at
the State Department and I have to be
successful in order to avoid war because
if you have diplomats who are not
successful that file of a problem gets
transferred over to the Pentagon and
they don't negotiate
they just solved the problem and so I
firmly believe that diplomats should be
at the forefront of pushing and prodding
and demanding talks and demanding that
we have a table to to you know air our
grievances on even before like if we're
planning to bomb if the if DoD is ready
to to attack I would hope that we have
brave diplomats that are saying wait a
minute I got one more chance let's sit
down
let's try the diplomacy thing so you
know I get hit constantly for Oh your
undiplomatic or you're too tough and I
thought that's what you want in the
diplomat because you want to have
somebody that's working hard to avoid
war who talk through through pushing and
prodding rather than transferring the
file over and and you know having a
problem solved through military action
has some of that been tough for you
though because you used to fight on
Twitter more or be more of like a
battler there where you know you you're
an ambassador now you're a guy in a
hoodie you've calmed it down a little
bit I still think that I pick my fights
I I don't feel like I've backed off what
I do think is that that I want to make
sure that someone is out in that fight
and so I look to see you know like I'm a
I'm a media bias issue I still get
really charged up if the groupthink in
Washington or the political circles is
one way and nobody's challenging that
I'm willing to jump in I don't care if I
have the title of ambassador I'm still
going to jump in and try to to push and
correct the record where I see fit if
others are doing it and thank god you're
in there to do it then sometimes I can
bill the ground support yeah I can let
it go and look for the next problem yeah
can you talk a little bit about just
generally what the state of the UN is
and what it was like to be there and you
know that so many people think that it's
like this sort of perfect thing that the
countries come together and figure out
what's right for everybody like they
love the idea of it more than I think
functionally how it works right or does
not work well first of all the I always
try to correct people that the UN
doesn't really exist the UN as member
states right so when somebody says oh
the UN says no I always said the UN
doesn't say no members at the UN maybe
Russia and China got together in the
Security Council and said no but the UN
doesn't take a position and so I try to
not just reflexively blame oh the UN and
stop something cuz it's really member
countries that's the first thing the
second thing is is the UN does not work
unless the u.s. is leading it
whether it's the World Food Program
UNICEF UNDP you know the development
programs whatever it is the US has to be
there otherwise the UN does not work the
UN system is based on every country is
equal not every person is equal it's
every country and that's where I think
as Americans we say that's just
fundamentally not true every country is
not equal so in the General Assembly
when we pretend that these small island
countries get the same vote as China or
the United States or you know the bigger
economies that's kind of laughable to be
honest I get that we want to have a
General Assembly where people have the
ability to talk but I don't love the
idea of one country one vote which i
think is balanced by the Security
Council in the and the idea that the
substantive work goes to the Security
Council so I get the kind of separation
but it's challenging to go to the UN and
participate in the system where the UN
says you know we have this formula and
every country gets to have a certain
amount of people get jobs at the UN so
they look at the formula and they say oh
how many people do we have from Nigeria
oh we need more go hire people into the
system from Nigeria it tends to not be
whether or not someone is qualified more
has the skill set it is
are we being fair and equal on the
disbursement of jobs all right and
that's where it breaks down because
you're hiring people that really don't
know what they're doing and they waste
money and the UN becomes a jobs program
is that you had better at certain things
and worse at others so like when it
comes to food disbursement or helping
development that kind of stuff it seems
like they're probably pretty decent at
and then the Security Council or a lot
of the rest of it seems like 90% of it
is just voting against the Israel yeah
you know yeah for sure
moving Iraq yeah I think you hit it on
the head is that you know we pay 25
percent of the UN bill and that's for
the Secretariat and the kind of UN
administration and all the parking
tickets right is the whole thing just
parking tickets
no it's exact
it's just ambassadors you get to park
wherever you want yeah but at the same
time there are these what they call
extra bodies independent bodies and
those are funded through voluntary
contributions so World Food Program in
UNICEF they don't get monies from the
the general fund of the 25% money that
we give UNICEF only gets its budget by
appealing to people say to say we've got
a crisis we need to go out and who wants
to write us a check the Europeans the
Germans the Americans we fund the most
on those World Food Program UNICEF type
independent bodies that's why they're
the well run isn't because we demand
management transparency and an
accountability in these independent
bodies we don't have that ability to do
in the UN General Assembly so the you
get this kind of really blob type
management and admission from the actual
UN operations what is the obsession with
Israel with the General Assembly I mean
every every time you look at that chart
it's like 9 percent of the condom
nations and well you know that there's
only one country that can't serve on the
Security Council
that's Israel I'm outraged by it I'm
telling you I think that the US
government should just put its foot down
and say we're gonna clear the deck and
Israel should be on the Security Council
just to prove a point of getting them on
the count on the Security Council it
there's this fascination with condemning
Israel it's why we got out of the Human
Rights Council is because you know
you've got nine resolutions on Israel
and nothing on you know Iran or or I
mean the word is out if you if you don't
want to be condemned by the UN and
you're a human rights abuser then go run
for the Human Rights Council checked
yourself right Trump somehow just gets
all this like he really has fixed a lot
of this or is in the process of fixing
it or you know he's not of the political
establishment and so he's willing to be
a disruptor we all know about this
of Technology and people who go in and
said gosh everybody has groupthink and
you're missing the big you know reform
effort I think Americans really want
Washington to be disrupted or the UN
they look at and they say what a waste
you know why are we spending all that
money but the system in Washington
filled with lobbyists and and all the
people that take care of each other they
don't want an outsider coming in and
somehow wrecking their good fortune you
know and and we see that in Hollywood we
see that same thing in Hollywood and so
I want to to applaud and do everything I
can for president Trump because first of
all he's got really thick skin all of
the people who just constantly come at
him for thank God we got a president
who's just really tough on that and
doesn't care and two he sees it for what
it is and he's not really that partisan
I mean I look at what I'm starting to to
call the Trump doctrine which I think
the Trump doctrine too foreign policy
which is a dual approach to every single
issue where you use every tool of the US
government economic tool sanctions
pressure to change the behavior of a
country and you really utilize that
pressure in a strong way at the same
time there's this separate path to say
let's talk let's sit down and have a
diplomatic talk he's doing it with Kim
jong-un and the the neocons and the
traditional Republicans did not like him
saying I'm gonna go just go talk to Kim
Jong moon they only want to do the
squeezing mm-hmm they don't always want
to say well why not talk to see if we
can test this talking is a tactic it's
not it's not the goal so when I see that
when you see then like the never Trump
conservatives so like the bill crystals
or just those guys that have sort of
been around forever and who usually
you've gotten everything wrong always
are they different privately like are
they privately kind of like yeah I like
what he's doing and he's I don't think
so I think the creatures of Washington I
think they live in Washington DC and
they they they want people to play by
the rules the people who benefit from
the rules and and they want everybody to
come in and play by the rules
are on both sides of the aisle this is
not a partisan thing at all it's you got
to come to our city and play by our
rules because we got lobbyists to take
care of and we've got a system and
everybody is participating in the system
Marco Rubio actually talked about this
just the other day and I thought it was
really good he was saying look when I
came to Washington and I didn't go to
their cocktail parties I eventually
didn't get invited to their cocktail
parties and then they started sniping at
me because I wasn't going to their
cocktail parties and I and they
recognized that I wasn't playing by
their rules
and he said Trump has done a 10-fold
he's come in and and you know completely
double down on that and and I think it's
right I think we're getting senators you
know Ron Johnson I think is another
great senator who doesn't play that game
and he comes from Wisconsin and and
plays a different you know tune which is
I'm fighting for the people of Wisconsin
Marco Rubio I think is doing that that
we have senators that are beginning to
do that and challenge the system and I
think it's what the people want so
what's it like when Trump Donald Trump
New York businessman Donald Trump the
guy becomes president then I assume your
phone rings one day and he says looking
looking to send somebody over to Germany
is it a phone calls it an email to
someone else reach out to you first as
well I so I had been in and around to
the campaign quite a bit and so there's
always a constant conversation and
there's also I think a question of like
who's loyal right who was here before
all of the jobs were available hmm who
was committed and I think they saw that
I was very committed in in the campaign
and so the conversation to me was you
know where do you see yourself in the
administration or do you want to join
the administration and so from the
beginning I just said you know some sort
of a foreign policy role you know let's
let's discuss and and then we had that
conversation and eventually I was like I
think Germany is good fit yeah so let's
actually back up because it's sort of
related to where you just head there so
you at one point when Romney was running
you
advisor for foreign policy for the
campaign right when when Romney was the
nominee yeah when he was the nominee
yeah and that was always a 2012 and this
is now it was really only for a couple
weeks because then some strange stuff
happened which is so related to
everything else we're talking about yeah
right I mean the reality is that it
wasn't a couple of weeks because I had
been on the prime in the primary doing
all this work so I hadn't been with him
for a long time they made it official
once he got the nominee nomination with
a bouquet with a big title but I had
already been there and doing all this
work just because you know I've worked
in foreign policy for a long time and as
a spokesman I know the media so I know
kind of how to define the issue and what
the media are thinking is the the the
issue or how they define it and then
being on the inside understanding where
we want to go having somebody to help
you get there right if the goal is here
and the media are here how do you how do
you educate and so with the
relationships that I had with with many
reporters it seemed like a natural fit
to be on the campaign as the the
spokesman but then as you're pointing to
I of course have been out for a very
long time and it written about then the
concern I wrote an article called the
conservative case for gay marriage
before the fight when we were fighting
it and many social conservatives at the
time didn't like the fact that Mitt
Romney had hired a openly gay foreign
policy spokesman and so they came they
came at me pretty hard and the campaign
pretty hard by saying this guy is for
gay marriage you know you're not how is
this gonna work so you got to finish
that story though so there so the story
ends with you stepping down voluntarily
right yes so I needed in that instance I
needed somebody to say this is
irrelevant this doesn't matter
he's our foreign policy spokesperson and
you know so you were looking for Donald
Trump then actually I was I was looking
for somebody that that would define
the issues for the Conservatives as you
know this is my campaign and this is my
beliefs and and to make the case and and
clearly the campaign knew that I was gay
before they hired me that should've been
a secret and so I was just looking for a
a protection and once I saw that you
know this is gonna be a complicated
issue for the campaign that they don't
know how they view this and their
reaction to me was you know it's best if
you just stay quiet and and not make any
waves for a while let's let this blow
over my reaction was well it's not gonna
blow over because I'm gay and - it's not
gonna blow over because it's a campaign
people like to inflate issues on
campaigns you it's now in your lap
you're gonna have to to solve this and
what I eventually saw was that it was
too complicated of an issue for them
they couldn't detangle it and they just
wanted me to stay quiet and as the
spokesman you can't stay quiet you're
the spokesman quiet spoken yeah so I I
consulted with a couple of my mentors
and they just said you know what just
just resign and and give them the
ability to go do what they want and so
they never replaced me actually on that
campaign so it's funny because I can see
you're being you're being honest
obviously but also slightly diplomatic
here right because you're not trying to
throw around me under the bus I get it
now what but without maybe speaking to
him specifically is is that thing that
you're talking about exactly what you're
describing Washington is yeah you know
eight inability to to grapple with
something straight forward let the media
do whatever they want and then all the
good people who are trying to do
something real are the ones that have to
resign or get thrown under the bus or or
the rest of it I mean I hope I'm not
like that guy that's like oh I'm the
purist and I'm the best and no you know
everybody should be like me because that
certainly is not the case I think though
Dave that that it's a good question and
I would say that the answer is more I
joined this kind of conservative
movement in 1992 and I had been
seen movement and and and I'm somebody
who the glass is always half full and so
I always try to make sure that we're
growing and changing the party from the
inside and so I I think the answer is is
I felt like there was change always
happening that we were on the right
trajectory and that even being hired was
a great moment and I'm not the candidate
right so so what I don't want to be the
story I really don't want I want to help
the candidate and so I recognized that I
had pushed as far as I could in that
particular situation and you know I
wrote an article I think a week later
saying how I think that that Mitt Romney
would be a better president than Barack
Obama and that I fully endorsed him so
I'm not sure that I'm being diplomatic
as I am being more truthful about the
progress and maybe I mean some people I
think could say you're jaded right
because you're been on the inside too
much that you weren't a purist and and
it's probably true I'm more of let's
let's have small improvements and as
long as we're making improvements and
the goal is up here I kind of you know
justify why I'm a part of the process so
Trump okay so let's just sort of piecing
this all together then now you have this
guy who you don't have to walk that
tightrope tightrope with we had 17
candidates in the in the primary and
Donald Trump really just suck out and so
I was really excited to work for him I
mean look this is a guy who who was very
clear in the in the campaign that that
he wanted to treat everybody the same he
really did and and so I liked working
for him because he was challenging us on
the Iraq war implementation and saying
you know
I thought it was a disastrous decision
he was critiquing Bush and McCain and
Romney's positions on the Iraq war in a
Republican primary mm-hmm now everybody
around me had said oh he's done but that
was all the Washington type people who
were playing by the rules and if you
took their rules he would have been done
but the primary is really about the
people outside of Washington and that's
where I felt like I was reading the
situation better than what they were
because my sphere wasn't what the
Washington crowd was was saying about
he's done and and he's not acting like a
Republican it was what the Republican
base or the people and how they were
responding to
yeah that's an obvious the Iraq war the
management didn't go well and so that
was an honest assessment of you know
some people say touching the third rail
of politics of saying the things you're
not supposed to say and I like that but
brick I don't understand everybody says
if you listen to the mainstream media
that everyone in the world they don't
respect this anymore and they think he's
a buffoon and all of these things could
that possibly not be true I mean that's
what the New York Times is telling us
I'm really joking aside like yeah what
are you seeing like as now as an
ambassador and when you go to all the
NATO things and all the places you go to
and all the meetings do you sense like
that people suddenly don't respect us
and they used to respect us they don't
or were or we're not the Patsy anymore
perhaps yeah like what is the real
temperature I think what you're really
asking is does his style work or does it
not work right compared to Barack Obama
style which is much different I think we
should be honest and and say we got two
different styles absolutely Washington
rulemaking will tell you that Trump
style does not work because they doesn't
participate in what their rules are but
let's look at that let's look at whether
or not his style works because I'll take
this argument all day long I don't want
to be political here but let's just talk
facts Barack Obama was wildly popular in
Germany wildly popular they loved him
didn't he give that speech but it was
before he was president when he was gay
like a million people crazy
any-any maintained his poppy
people loved him but he didn't get any
of his signature programs or policies
through and and I mean that you look at
TTIP which was the economic signature
program of the Obama administration the
Germans killed it
they literally led the fight to kill it
Nordstrom - we said don't build it they
went ahead and built it JA Kapali
the Nazi prison guard living in New York
City for 12 years the US courts said get
him out of here he lied to us we want
him back in Germany the Germans wouldn't
take him the entire eight years of the
Obama administration they asked will you
take this Nazi prison guard back they
ignored him defense spending we asked
some very nice ways can you raise your
defense spending you know we think that
you should be a better man a NATO member
they largely didn't do it and so all of
those issues were were solved under the
Trump administration so I've actually
said to Chancellor Merkel in to the
Foreign Minister and to others in
Germany you're gonna have to deal with
some tough tweets yeah you're gonna have
to deal with some pushing and some
ribbing because the only way that we can
read this is that the Donald Trump style
has worked do you think they secretly
liked it but sort of publicly I don't
mean Germany specifically but generally
that countries and leaders they have to
sort of pretend that they don't like
Trump but as they see the u.s. sort of
reassert itself and maybe even as he
forces them to pay a little bit more
actually pay their share that in a weird
way they almost do like it because it
helps give them a little bit of their
sovereignty back or or the ownership to
look for another at that's 100 percent
for sure I think the public's in Europe
like to have the ability to have their
sovereignty back they they love and
President Trump has said this to
Chancellor Merkel I don't blame you for
not paying your NATO bill right and find
cheap Russian gas and having a 69
billion dollar surplus over us and
having a surplus and 50,000 American
troops protecting you I don't blame you
who wouldn't do that if you were the
Chancellor of Germany so but then he
says but now it stops here because
you're outsmarted all these other
president
and now I have to stick up for my people
so if Trump is right about all this
stuff and now countries are paying more
and all of these witches it he is
totally right yeah so granted so nearly
so times a bill right so suddenly
countries are starting to pay their
share is it just is it just what you're
saying that it was just the way
Washington always worked and that it or
is it just that we've refused to use any
influence on countries like that we were
just it was just always easier to just
be like ah we'll pay for everything or
you know what I mean like I think it's
some of it is our own fault and and
you're getting that that's what I guess
that's what I'm asking that it was just
we kept bringing in people that just
were always like oh we're paying and why
wouldn't we pay yeah and we got to be
nice and now they're pushing back and we
want to be pro-european and and so let's
just have a dinner party and and you
know a lot of parties yeah and sitting
in European capitals and really you know
we spent we have all of these people in
European capitals working at our
embassies I look I think our embassies
should be mini commerce sections you
know I've got a whole bunch of people at
the Embassy who are super smart and and
very committed to the United States and
do great public service but I have come
to the conclusion that having a whole
team of people watching the German
political system and reporting back to
Washington by writing cables about
what's happening in in the governor's
race Minister presidents race in a state
in Germany and all of that stuff super
interesting completely irrelevant in
many ways we can get that information
off the internet after it happens we
don't need reporting officers to do that
what we do need our economic specialists
on LNG liquid natural gas or economic
specialists on medical devices to help
us get us companies growing in Europe I
think that our embassies need to be
transformed less on the political side
less about the politics of the country
that we can get through the internet all
this was established before we had the
internet and now we need to turn these
these embassies into America first
economic models just like what other
countries do we're the only country in
the world that gets in trouble for
pushing
our self forward everybody's doing it
but we're the one that gets in trouble
for saying oh how dare you yeah did you
by any chance read that book that I've
got right there you're Omar's oniy the
virtue of nationalism no because his
whole his whole idea of reading we're
toast marries though oh there you go
well there's plenty of there's a couple
good Douglas Murray books over here but
the basic premise of the book is that
strong nations that you have to be a
strong nation first so be America first
be Germany first be whatever your
country is first and that's how you by
being a strong nation first then you can
create some sort of international
community that makes sense but that
really were just doing it all backward
or we've been doing it backwards for
decades which is we put ourselves down
and the thinking that we're achieving
some higher goal or something and then
we rend it we end up screwing over
everybody yeah I think that makes a lot
of sense in and you know sometimes you
have to be able to put forward in a in a
pushy way your position in order to get
things done and that doesn't mean that
the relationship is ruined but it just
means that this is a priority and so
you're gonna push it harder I think
that's been one of the problems that
we've had is just the this kind of
status quo let's all you know you're
supposed to say what you want and I'm
supposed to say what I want and then we
we kind of cut the baby in half and we
go away and and go to lunch to me that's
not diplomacy I mean we have to be able
to push forward our agenda by the way
I've never I've been in thousands of
diplomatic discussions thousands I've
never been in one where the other side
doesn't ask for something and we ask for
something in return it happens all the
time yeah this is called diplomacy
what do you want what do I want you know
it's this whole thing and the idea that
you're asking for something is not a
quid pro quo
it's called diplomacy this is exactly
what we do is we show up to a meeting
and we give our agenda of what we'd like
you to do and what we need and then you
do that and we pick and choose and when
you make it a priority this is what I
would say on the jacket poly the the
Nazi prison guard thing when I showed up
in Germany and I made this a priority
and I said this return of the not super
guard I brought it up in my first
meeting with the foreign minister and
you know what the foreign minister said
to me after I bought it up I've never
heard of this case huh okay that's
incredible the State Department had told
me oh we've asked for 12 years it's it's
gonna go nowhere but you should bring it
up in my Senate confirmation I got a
written question will you make JA Kapali
the return of the Nazi prison guard will
you make it a priority I said yes and I
said I did it and then President Trump
said to me you should really get that
Nazi prison guard returned I'm like I'm
on it
I brought it up in every meeting I made
it a priority
I had to educate them they returned him
does Trump basically just say do
whatever you want
until no not-not-not not fully that but
like this BAE's Betty I sense what he
does with people is he gets people he
kind of likes and trusts and let them do
their thing and then he gets involved in
some way after that or something like
that what I would say is is I'll give
you the perfect example he gave me he
called one day and said we're getting
killed on medical devices and I was like
oh I don't know anything about it he
goes I know but you'll figure it out and
I said I'm on it I'll report back and
tell you what we're getting killed on
yeah and what what I think the solution
is and he's like good make it soon so
suddenly you have a directive from the
president to figure it out so what do I
do I immediately go out and I meet with
the medical device companies in Germany
and then the ones providing jobs in the
United States and then the US ones
figure out what your problems we've
figured out what the problem was or I
should say one of the problems a big
problem and then we tackle it and we try
to deal with the whole FAA and US trade
negotiator and to be an ambassador I
think you have to be able to know how to
work the interagency process of the US
government you've got to be an expert on
the US government not an expert on
giving dinner parties you have to be an
expert on how to maneuver within the US
government to help companies I helped
German companies only if they have US
jobs
I view my job as solely trying to create
more economic opportunity for Americans
more jobs better paying jobs and so that
can be done through Lufthansa the great
German airline who has 15,000 American
employees that can be done through
Siemens that has 60,000 American
employees BMW in South Carolina so I'm
constantly trying to help grow American
jobs but sometimes it's through German
companies so I thought it would be an
interesting way to end which is that
when we met so I sorted we knew each
other about five years ago just through
Twitter the way everyone knows everybody
but I was a lefty at the time you know I
was a full-on progressive I worked at
the Young Turks and I had you on my show
one time you came in and you were the
scary conservative and it was a very
different show than this and we just did
Hot Topic kind of stuff but it was very
clear that the other panelists didn't
like you and we disagreed on some stuff
and whatever doesn't matter like me you
were you I remember it was specifically
we were talking it was right before
Christmas and we were talking about you
know how everybody's going crazy at
stores for Black Friday and everything
and you were saying how great it is and
people are out there and there shondo
shopping and they and they were
basically saying oh you capitalist Pig
anyway doesn't even matter the specifics
but I mentioned all that because I would
just assume that you must be pretty
freaking thrilled at the way the world
is tracking that now it's four or five
years later and you see someone like me
who was you know a former lefty that
even though I think we still have some
minor political disagreements doesn't
even matter what it is but that there
really is like this rich thing happening
on the conservative side right now yeah
and for somebody that was an out gay
conservative way before you know really
there was anybody out there you must be
pretty happy that it that it does feel
like a pretty freakin wide tent right
now I also feel pretty cool for a
question I often do something I also
feel pretty old when I look at being at
the 1992 convention being friends with
Andrew Breitbart when Andrew Breitbart
came to me and said CPAC is not allowing
gays to have a boot the log cabin and I
was like Andrew it's ridiculous and he's
like what do you think if I boycott
and I was like you'll be a hero and then
he did and then he had this huge party
and just transformed I mean so much of
what Andrew Breitbart did and and this
is not an endorsement of everything that
right back I'm tired it's so sad you
have to say that with almost everything
these days
I like qualified but Andrew you know who
helped launch the Huffington Post and
what I met him when he was working for
Arianna Huffington and you know I I
guess the answer is is that the fight
and debate for making our country better
is something that I'm really passionate
about and I've seen the the utility of
the fight in the debate as long as you
do it in a respectful way I have to say
one of the most hurtful things when I
went through confirmation is how the
left completely took you know two or
three of my tweets that were meant to be
funny
yeah and turned him into a sexist I mean
I became the sexist thing and and you
know Democratic senators took to the
floor and we're like he's a sexist they
didn't even know me yeah in fact some of
those Democratic senators have asked 11
times to meet with me and they've
refused to meet me Courtney well also
the whole time during your cut well
first up they kept delaying your
confirmation to write so they're saying
Trump hates gay people Trump's got the
openly gay guy you're trying to get
confirmed as ambassador and there's even
a semester I mean it's such a mess and
and so all I'm saying is is that I
always feel like a thoughtful debate
right tolerance diversity right I can
sit I have so many liberal friends I can
sit with my liberal friends have a good
discussion I sometimes learn from them
well that's interesting they learn from
me this is what happened with I think
your journey I have the some of the same
journey I don't have the same views as I
had 89 years ago everybody changes if
you're listening in the debate you are
absolutely going to learn and change I
can't believe it took us so long to do
this you had to go beat your bass here
Jeremy and bounce they're all over the
world it was a pleasure my friend next
time I'm wearing a hoodie and you're
gonna
how does that sound can I just say that
I think you have the best show on the
Internet we do not have the ability to
talk about issues like this thank you
for doing it I know that it's not always
easy but it's huge it's huge and it's so
healthy and for everybody that's
listening to these debates and learning
if you're in your car or whatever I mean
it's amazing it's amazing we need more
of this not not less follow up on
Twitter at Richard Grinnell if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell